So, based on last week and the week
before that and the week before that,
I had a Hang on, let me move some stuff
out of the way.
I had a fairly low opinion
of quite a lot of the literature in RL
already.
It seems I was wrong.
It is in fact much worse than expected.
Nothing works.
Practically,
theoretically,
nothing works.
The only thing that does work is puffer.
So, here's the question.
Puffer is high data regime, low comput
RL. That is what I've optimized for.
That is what I've built puffer for.
If instead of doing fancy things,
complicated new algorithms, if we just
kind of reoptimize a little bit for
sample efficiency
with a reasonable compute trade-off, not
what's being done in the literature, not
like literally 10 hours of compute to
match one minute of compute and puffer,
but some reasonable tradeoff.
How far can we get?
I don't think we're going to be able to
get
this.
I don't think we're going to be able to
match the sample efficiency of results
on paper, but then again, those don't
actually work.
So, we're going to see how far we can
get.
Most actual real world applications do
not care about this to the extent
whatsoever as is presented in the
literature.
They just care about it to more of an
extent than we have now.
Also, I'm sick of driving myself insane
uh dealing with fancy algorithms that do
not work. So, we're going to do things
my way. We're going to see how far we
get.
Hello, something. What do you mean
sample efficiency doesn't work? I mean,
why? Go try any of the methods from the
literature. Go try their reference
implementations. Try them on new
problems. Look at the code. See how fast
it is. Tell me if anything makes any
bloody sense.
I've spent three weeks determining that
in fact it does not.
Just adjust the mic so I stop clipping
it.
Hello, Jess.
I believe I have some experiments from
over the weekend. We had a fun power
outage in my cluster
and the electricians have not set up the
UPS yet for some bloody reason. So that
means some stuff got killed, which
sucks.
Yeah. So, this was the old neural MMO
run.
It's a nice curve.
We're going to have to go rerun it.
What's the best paper on sample
efficiency that you've read? Apparently,
none of them because they don't actually
work.
There's literally not a single one that
like I can say actually works. It's that
bad.
I can tell you well-written papers that
don't actually work,
but there's no point.
No, RL is definitely not useless. We
have it working and we have it working
incredibly well in a range that's
already very useful.
So, you know, we're absolutely certain
that RL is useful.
It might end up being the case, right,
that there simply is not uh a good
tradeoff to get to the level of sample
efficiency presented in the literature.
Now, but even in that case, like RL is
still incredibly useful. It just puts
slightly more emphasis on having good
simulators.
I certainly wouldn't have sp spent a
decade on my life on something that I
thought had the potential to be entirely
useless.
Let's take a look at some experiments.
I did a few small things. Okay,
so
here was the first set of experiments I
ran on breakout.
This is only 10 million steps. I
literally just reran the optimization
with a limit of 10 million steps. That's
all I did.
And you know, you get close to solving
And then I reran
with I believe a slightly larger
network.
And this is
I don't know if this is actually a full
solve, but this is almost a solve,
right? Like 850 plus typically. So this
is like almost a solve with just a
slightly bigger network.
Admittedly, the trade-off is not great.
you'd expect to get more out of the
network size, but still.
And then we had um our more recent runs
crash.
So, we really didn't get to see
what happens over here. Okay.
But I think what we're going to start
with
start with this.
Let's grab this run.
These two are very close.
You tr use transfer learning.
That does not work at all.
That I can tell you does not work at
all.
Why? Because so if you're trying to draw
an analogy between how this works in
supervised learning, it's like trying to
train on only cats, like classify cats,
and then try to get it to work on some
other random class.
That's not how it works, right? If you
want transfer, you train on like a
thousand different instances and then
you get it to work on a new one better.
If you train on like one very narrow
task, you're going to get a
representation that's very specific to
that task.
Isn't that metal learning? Yes, that
does not actually work across tasks
like very different tasks. It works from
distributions of tasks to similar tasks.
Not exactly.
It doesn't map in RL the way that you
expect it to map from supervised
replay. It's not that they're useless.
They are very useful, but it's it's
architecturally very very difficult to
uh to integrate them in a way that is
sensible.
Are off pole methods completely useless?
Uh the current ones in the current state
that they are presented. Yes.
I can outline the the problem that you'd
have to solve to make them to work in
addition to reoptimizing for like a more
reasonable compute to sample regime. Uh
in order to make them useful,
you'd have to solve the very short
bootstrap horizon problem that they
have. That's the main issue. it's that
they have a very short bootstrap
horizon. And actually, they're not even
off Paul because as soon as you go
beyond bootstrap horizon one, you
actually have an onpaul assumption.
And they kind of just ignore that. And
uh literally this cause this causes like
all sorts of different degeneracies.
So, I mean, like I posted, right? I'm
sick of clever researchers coming up
with all sorts of very fancy ways to
make things that only work on paper.
Async PO.
Uh, nope. Because of the exact same
thing with like the exact same onpaul
requirement. The only Okay, the most
reasonable version of this I've seen is
clean, which is what exactly one epoch
off policy.
That is a reasonable thing to do for
like high throughput RL.
Um, what I'm doing right now is
pretty dang good,
I'd say. And even one epoch offp can
hurt you. I don't know if there's been a
a really good study. You'd want what
you'd want to do is take clean button,
see how much it actually hurts you to be
one epoch off Paul. I imagine that it
actually can be quite substantial, but
that is the best thing that we have in
my opinion.
Your replay buffer. No, you don't have a
a replay buffer in that you have one
epoch off Paul. It's different.
You can't just naively do a replay
buffer. It doesn't work. I tried.
Working on Labor Day. Exactly. It's
Labor Day. Not sit on your ass and do
nothing day.
This is sketchy. These hypers are
sketchy. I can see. Well, we'll try
them, but these are super sketchy. Pams
low clip co.
I'm actually like completely and utterly
exhausted um today. Let me I have good
reason for it. Hang on. Let me show off
the uh
here. Let me show off the uh the recent
side project that I've been working on.
No, I did not run a marathon.
Not a full one. I mean, not recently at
least,
but
What month is it? August.
All right. So, this is why I'm freaking
exhausted.
We are at 130 miles in the last
realistically three weeks.
I did 16 miles yesterday and then I got
up and did six this morning. plus
lifting.
Yes, I will release an article, but I
think I'm going to do it once I actually
have some of this stuff working.
Okay. Yeah. So, this was the concern.
Um, whenever I see this param getting
set this way, it's always like super
unstable.
Oh, you know what? I suppose wasn't this
a different number of M's?
Hang on.
Maybe I'm not being fair to it. You look
like you lost some weight. I've lost a
lot of weight.
I'm at like a average cut of at least
1,000 calories a day.
I'm losing like between two and four
pounds per week.
Honestly, that's the easy part. like the
cut very very easy. The training not so
much.
What do you think would be a reasonable
SPS goal for my chess hub?
I'd chat with bet a little bit. Um, so I
know chess engines evaluate like tens of
millions of positions per second.
The only thing I don't know with your
chess MV is because the if you have the
gigantic flat action space that is going
to cause data transfer issues and such
like that's going to make the training
difficult to be fast. I don't know if
there's like a a reasonable
multi-discreet representation
right that you could do. Um,
you might have to look into that a
little bit, but like the actual game, I
don't see any reason that can't be a
million plus SPS.
Eating food is easy. Not eating food.
Other way around for me, man. I'm
literally I still have to stuff myself
to get all of my calories in. Even on a
cut,
Okay. So, this is better,
but not amazing.
What are you working on today? I'm just
going to try to retune a little bit for
higher
sample efficiency. I'm going to play
around with some different techniques to
enable scaling to slightly larger
networks. Just some basic things.
Yeah. The other thing that helps is it
turns out when you go run 16 miles, like
12 ounce steak and eggs for brunch and
then like steak dinner counts as being
on a cut
if you just burn a stupid number of
calories.
Well, to be fair, man, I I ran the first
half marathon of it and I had to walk
the last couple miles home. It was
brutal yesterday. It was 90. It was over
90 degrees in direct sun with no breeze
by the time I finished. Um,
like I did a half marathon last weekend,
eight out of 10 effort. No preparation,
no supplies, easy. This weekend I was
like dying. And I prepped it as well. I
had Gatorade packs with me. Uh, I had
shop blocks. I had electrolytes. I went
through like 10 plus bottles of water
while I was out there and I got back the
entire hat that I have. It's like
crusted in salt all the way through the
hat. It's just like insane.
So yesterday was brutal.
Yeah, it's not a cool down when uh a
decent chunk of those are just like
brutal hills.
Yeah, that was that was rough.
510 pounds in water. Yeah, I actually
replace it though. There's a water
fountain every 5K. So every 5K I would
drink like I'd fill my bottle up. I'd
drink a bottle of water. I'd fill the
bottle back up, add a Gatorade pack, and
then I drink that on the next lap. So I
was getting two bottles of water at
least per loop.
off Paul. I tried SACE.
Um I tried like Mr. Q. Uh and then I
guess it world model based stuff.
Dreamer.
Nothing works. Like literally nothing
works.
is reward from breaking blocks delayed.
Um I mean credit assignment is generally
like one of the core challenges of RL as
a whole. So
yeah I the way to think about why I do
break like why I do so much stuff on
breakout uh you're thinking too much
about the reasoning behind it. It is
that empirically breakout is very fast
to solve and it is the simplest task
where when something does well on
breakout it is actually typically
indicative of uh broader progress.
Why did you post a ton of results but
not label what the curves are?
Man's got to have his secrets.
I don't know. Sometimes I just post
random sweeps. Kevin.
All right, this one looks better. This
one has like a non- stupid clip
coefficient. So, if we're going to do uh
any sort of analysis, it's going to be
off of this one.
Uh
yeah,
although I wanted to just do it for
learning. Wait. C for future works
overall. You think I should leave it?
What do you mean? Wait. Offpaul.
Although I just wanted to do it for
learning C
for future. I was thinking using offball
for experience replacements past. Well,
I just wanted to do it for learning. I
don't understand how those two things go
together.
Uh the So, here's the the tough thing.
Let me be very clear about this.
Off-poly algorithms are fundamentally
worse than on policy algorithms because
they don't have the nice long bootstrap.
They don't have generalized advantage
estimation. It's not easy to learn value
functions. They compensate by doing a
utterly stupid number of updates on the
data repeatedly using a replay buffer.
So if you invest the same amount of
compute, you're going to do a lot better
with on policy than you are with off
policy. If you crank up the compute
ridiculously though, off policy will do
better.
Sometimes,
not even consistently,
because most of these off-paul
algorithms actually have implicit onpaul
assumptions,
just not as strong ones you'll find
everywhere else.
You can make a project to train an RL on
a CM to learn how to make an image.
DIP techniques pixel by pixel. I don't
know what DIP is.
Uh just generally I would suggest making
any environment that actually makes
technical sense like this is a
reasonable problem that you think you
can do with RL and that you're going to
be interested enough to actually do and
complete is generally a good enough
idea. Like you want to be doing cool
projects that are like interesting in
some new way cover some like aspect that
maybe we haven't considered and that
you're going to be have enough fun doing
to actually complete.
typically about it using pure
I don't know how
you basically you just have to come up
with a reason for like how on earth
that's an RL problem right so you don't
want to just like turn a sequence
modeling problem into an RL problem
there actually has to be a meaningful
element of interactivity for it to make
sense
process what do you mean the standard is
just MLP
like our standard is LSTM Um, what's the
thought process for using LSTM? It's
very simple. The reason people don't use
LSTMs is because their code sucks and
they don't actually have like an
implementation that can do it fast. If
you can do it, it's just better.
It's like the single most stable thing
that we have like working well is just
having a good LSTM implementation.
There's like there's literally no
fundamental reason not to do it. It's
just the standard because people can't
code. literally it
like if you go check the standard
implementations SP3 doesn't even have it
and uh if you check clean RL they do it
in this really inefficient loop that
makes everything 5x slower
but if you actually do it correctly it's
an incredibly efficient architecture and
it's like a really really good backbone
Tim isn't that hard to code though. Oh,
really? Go take a look at the puffer
implementation and then tell me if you
think that.
Yeah, their contra technically does.
They never got it in the main the main
repo,
which is kind of funny with how core it
is.
So, this is like 700ish
700 score.
I'm not trying to be a dick, by the way,
Kevin. It's just like it is actually
hard to do it in a way that is fast.
Like, it's not trivial.
How did you know to use LSTM when you
built Popper Dota?
It's the core piece of Dota. Good enough
for me.
I don't know how you form um vision as
an RL problem efficiently.
Um maybe. But the thing is it so RL's
never just memory, right? It's also
credit assignment. So you also have to
get credit assignment to work over that
horizon. And if you want credit
assignment to work over that horizon
then
like effectively you want
you want gamma times lambda not just
gamma but you want gamma time lambda to
be very high
and empirically that doesn't seem to
happen.
So based on the hyperparameters I've
seen for optimal run so far, I would
doubt it. And there's really no way to
get like the 1k plus step memory without
horribly inefficient and like slow
models
controls the cameras.
So but like why don't you just do
supervis like supervised learning is
just easier than RL, right? You get way
more signal.
So it's not like generally you don't
want to try to form supervised learning
problems as RL problems. You're looking
for problems that can't be done via
supervision alone because it's
fundamentally interactive. That's what
you're looking for in RL.
Yeah. one third the infra.
This is also true. RL is hard. Like RL
is legitimately hard.
Okay, so these runs were just kind of
lucky. I don't think that there's like a
huge difference then between this one
and
there's still kind of a difference,
right?
Yeah, now there's still kind of a
difference. Okay, so we get 700s out of
this.
I hate narls that
for things we can solve much easily. We
do a lot of effort.
There a lot of problems with LL itself.
Yes, there are. I mean, you see, I'm
here trying to fix them though, right?
There are a ton of problems.
This is what I do.
I fix them.
Okay. So,
best solution, professor.
Uh, it might not be for Pokemon
specifically because that end is so slow
that like honestly you would have just
not had that hard of a time with that
problem if Pokemon ran a million steps a
second.
Like just the the amount of problems
that just go away with high uh high
sample like high simulator speed. It's a
lot.
I solve problems.
What is Neptune site you use? Uh, it's
an alternative to wand to be
simple grid base with a deterministic
end. Not a single work on sparse reward.
Yesesh.
Uh you can see we have plenty of sparse
reward RL working right.
Okay. So
things to do from here.
There are a lot of different sweeps we
can run, right?
I should probably be able to like pretty
easily spin up.
Did I literally forget what I named my
machines?
Jeez.
Hang on. Let me go check tail scale to
make sure they're up and that I haven't
just forgotten.
[Music]
Weird.
Yeah, I didn't forget. It's literally
they're just down. Okay, that sucks.
Well, we'll have these rebooted shortly.
In the meantime,
suppose there are a few different things
we can do.
If I set frame skip
to one
Okay. Well, this is going to be rebooted
momentarily anyways,
Okay. So there is actually a
self-consistency loss.
Okay, here.
Here's the ablation.
equ= 10.
What is standard?
No weight decay.
So actually it looks like these resets
are the most important thing.
Weight decay.
The kneeling.
I actually do wonder. We've never played
with weight decay.
It's possible that when you play with
larger nets, you need weight decay.
Actually, this
I do wonder about this um
this scaling here.
There's probably a fair bit we can do.
increasing discount factor.
This could be good for both
overfitting because you don't have
enough data.
Um, so Weston the re the motivation is
because we're trying to do lower data
regime. So in the lower data regime if
you overparameterize it's possible,
right?
And we can also very easily just test it
empirically.
This is not a huge thing. Honestly,
still be a worse way of doing things.
The the point here, Weston,
right now, if you have a fast simulator,
Puffer is the best thing out there.
Puffer also gives you some tools to make
your simulator fast. You can't always
make your simulator fast, though. What
I'm trying to do is I'm trying to expand
the range of problems for which Puffer
is effective. And I'm trying to do so
smoothly in a way that doesn't really
have any negative trade-offs. Do you see
what I mean?
Very
Oh, you dummy. I forgot. Uh,
Hang on. There's a key hyperparameter I
forgot.
Hang on. Let me not be dumb.
example,
uh, full games,
fancy robotics,
existing industry sims in a variety of
fields where they want to like try
something out before rewriting a full
full on sim.
How much variance between training runs?
No, those are different hypers, Tim.
That's not variance across runs. Those
are completely different hypers.
It's expected that there's that much
variance. Puffer is actually Puffer is
pretty good on not having crazy variance
for most M.
Uh, this is kind of funny. Look at this.
Some of these sample efficient
algorithms actually just stop being good
when you train them for longer. That's
hilarious. That's actually consistent
with what I saw.
Pablo generally does pretty good work.
I think just like offpaul stuff is super
cursed, so I don't trust everything, but
Pablo generally does pretty good work.
I've chatted with him several times at
different conferences.
What did these guys get on? Um
you surely you put the full Atari
results right
out
here. 370. This is respectable.
I always look to break out. It's my like
go-to task.
[Music]
That's kind of promising now.
but we're going to just have to do
and go to the new box.
I'm so confused. What happens?
Why do I not have
Oh, there it is. Forgot about the
username being different.
This is going to honestly
like
this is going to be much more chill this
week doing this type of stuff for a
little bit.
My brain needs a break from banging my
head against overly complicated things
that don't actually work. It's very
demotivating.
Yeah, but we're going to fix that.
We're like actually going to fix that.
I almost feel like it would have been
better for me to take some time off
today. I'm like freaking smoked.
Well,
I think I kind of am doing that now.
This is going to be pretty easy work
today.
We'll see. I might do shorter hours. It
kind of depends on how the work is going
today.
I might end up doing shorter hours. I
might uh if I'm making progress, I'll be
here all day, though.
The run yesterday like really really did
a number on me.
I was like I was expecting to do a hard
run. I thought I was going to get like
between 16 and 18 miles. I did not
expect it to be remotely that hard.
Why you think don't leverage RL more for
coding tasks?
They are doing that. Um, that's exactly
what they're doing now. Their [ __ ] is
slow because their models are slow and
RL likes lots of data.
It's also very difficult to teach
because like
the learning signal for programming is
not trivial.
the thing is at least in RL even before
the model scaled like the researchers
and PhD students just wrote such shitty
code that their stuff didn't work
anyways.
I'll agree though in natural language
processing at least before transformers
it was substantially easier to do
research. Now, I mean, I will say that
like
you shouldn't just try to fight that
stuff headon, right? Like, if your idea
is, oh, all these like big models, you
need big models to do stuff. Well, I'm
going to just like not do it. Like, I'm
going to just try to do big models
anyways, even though I don't have any
compute and have like a horrible
research cycle time, etc., etc. Like,
you're just not doing stuff reasonably,
right? At that point, you shouldn't be
doing a PhD. you should just be going to
industry. If you have things that you
can explore without being super
constrained, that's a different story.
Well, because Jess, like the thing is
they're kind of right about this in some
ways at least. Like when I was doing
research in natural language processing
in 2017, you needed a different PhD for
translation
or for uh language modeling or for like
semantic analysis. They were very
different problems with distinct methods
and then they kind of just all got soded
with the same approach, right?
Similar stuff happened in vision few
years before that.
But at this point, you are correct that
people are trying to overgeneralize in
some sense where it doesn't even
remotely make sense.
Yeah, you can't do anything like you
should not be doing VLM research
training um as a PhD student. Like
you're just not going to have a good
time. I don't know why you would set
yourself up for failure.
robotics. It is
there's tons of stuff that you can do.
You just have to be a bit creative. Now,
to be fair,
uh I will give you this though, right?
You can definitely make very good
scientific progress without having a ton
of researcher uh resources. Whether or
not entrenched academic idiots will
recognize like out there ideas
um and actually prop that stuff up is a
totally different story.
Being a PhD student is just generally
not a lot of fun,
even in the best of circumstances. At
least if you're not doing if you're not
like the textbook academic, it's not a
lot of fun.
If you're working on a project area
that's not super compute limited that is
actively explored and you're working
like within a realm of like
algorithmically heavy things, right? And
there have been many stages in many
different subfields where this has been
the case over the last decade, then it's
a good time.
Well, mostly.
But that's a lot of ifs and buts.
Does anybody know what a reasonable
weight decay scale is for Muan?
Transformers are pretty dang different
architecture really.
What's reasonable weight, decay, range,
scale,
or move on?
I don't know. Is it 1 E6? Is it 1 E4? Is
it? It's not like one E minus one,
right? But it could be like minus 4
minus I don't know. I just want to
range.
Rock take for freaking ever.
It literally doesn't even give you a
reasonable uh a reasonable range. Stupid
thing. All right, we'll just give it a
wide range then. It gives me a total
[ __ ] answer after all that.
Uh, wait. Underscore decay. I see you
use Grock a lot. Is there a reason the
models are all stupid? Anyways,
uh, if you see a lot of my work, there's
pretty little involvement.
Like, there's pretty little LLM
involvement in any of my work.
I don't know. I suppose I'm one of the
the uh the hold outs.
Like I just generally do not think that
these things are consistently useful.
grabbing that from Muan. Yeah, I know.
But I didn't ask for LLM training. It
just assumed cuz it's stupid.
Good for generalization, not specific.
So that's useless.
I ban like between two and five of those
a day.
how much you're allowed to say? I can
say everything. Every anything I signed
is long expired by now. What was your
time working at OpenAI like? Uh, I've
been very public in saying it's the best
place I've ever worked by a mile. Like,
it's pretty much the only place I've
ever worked where at least the vast like
the majority of the people there were
incredibly competent. Like actually gave
a [ __ ] about what they were doing. Um, I
was there when they were building Dota.
It's I still consider that probably the
most impressive technical project in RL
of all time.
Um,
there were like a whole bunch of
different small different sized like
mini research labs doing different
stuff. Robotics was awesome. I directly
used some of their domain randomization
results in my work on neural MMO. There
was like a more fragmented multi- aent
team. There was Alec that was there
doing LLM stuff. Ilia was there. Greg
was there. Obviously, everybody just
like chatted about RL like and research
at lunch all day.
Uh, it was really great. Now, I I don't
know how it's changed since I've been
there. I would assume that it's
impossible to keep that talent density
as you get larger. Um,
at the very least, you can't keep like
the small team vibes and like the
different like focuses on different
areas. I very much wish that they'd at
least kept like 20% of their people on
different areas of research, but like
the rest of the field kind of everybody
consolidated 99% onto LLMs. And
ultimately, we're going to look back on
that as uh a detriment to science and
something that delayed progress for
several years. which is why I am here
holding down the Ford on RL because I
think that this is important and all of
my all of my good friends who used to
work on it for the most part like very
few of them are still in the space and
we lost some very very good people to go
over and work on LLM research and
ultimately we're going to recognize that
that was a bad move for science overall
but it's okay I've got it I'll make sure
that this at least this one piece of
science science that was cast to the
wayside is done well and uh achieves the
potential it should it should have
achieved years ago.
There is a kneeling and such.
What do you hope the field will explore
once LM dies down? Exactly what I'm
doing now, right?
I mean, there's other stuff I could do.
Um,
the idea of like recursive
self-improvement is pretty interesting
to me as a whole. Like, why the hell do
these systems not actually recursively
self-improve?
like at a fundamental level it's kind of
weird.
That was the sort of the theory back in
the day, right? That you were going to
get an exponential takeoff. You weren't
just going to get log linear progress
with compute forever.
And
I mean like we have people now saying,
"Oh yeah, that was just completely
stupid." No, it wasn't. You have no idea
what the hell could have happened,
right?
Everything's hindsight's 2020. You
actually have no idea of or
understanding of how these systems might
have possibly behaved or why.
I suppose one theory is that they are
exponentially improving depending on how
you measure in some ways, but you're
still not getting
not in all the ways that you would
expect at the very least.
Okay, so we've gotten a few different
things done here. Right now, let's go
go implement a couple of them.
Keeping good samples is the value,
right? So you can't keep good
uh Tim, I'm pretty sure that's the
issue. It's difficult because
technically policy gradient itself, even
without the value function, the
derivation assumes that the samples come
from the same policy. But if you look at
the final result of that derivation, it
really does seem like it's just the
value function. Hello Nicholas, I'm
currently doing MSSE in economics and
could have been Python. I'm doing a
project in Marl and repeated games. Want
to know your advice on progressing in
coding of this type. What do you think
of Julia? Yeah, absolutely not Julia for
AI stuff. Um, you're going to be doing
Python. Python is standard. Uh, all the
tools that you need are in there. And
then low-level stuff. If you actually
need to do environment dev and stuff, uh
I suggest C for that. And you can take a
look at puffer lib as a very detailed
example and all the articles we have on
exactly how and why that works well.
We're not too early to explore the
stars.
There are lots of problems for me to
solve after this. I don't necessarily
see myself doing like core RL research
for the rest of my life. Right? In my
mind, this is a problem to be solved.
I'm going to solve it and then I'm going
to do other things.
right, that's like a good number of
little things tried. I think with this,
we can reserve those last two GPUs for
whatever I come up with based on this
thing.
I don't know how much I trust that like
no resets thing as well.
Have you tried gymnasium?
No, I've only spent the last two years
working uh building a framework around
it and replacing it. Oh, at Nicholas.
I see. It was sarcastic. My bad, Jess.
Uh yeah, Nicholas, if you just take a
look at Puffer, it's literally a
thousand times faster. Like check out
the Discord, join like join up, take a
look at start like running some
experiments there. You'll see the
difference immediately.
No, this is not about not resetting the
N. This is them resetting the network
weights. Um there's like this weird
thing with plasticity
where like the net is easier to train
for the first many updates.
It's a really weird thing.
I was like what the heck is that
question Jess is this person just like
not you've been a around for a while
just like not seen like watched anything
on the screen. I'm pretty sure I have
gymnasium bin ports at the top of half
of the files in here, even though I'd
love to get rid of them.
Like, frankly, the only stuff we're
using from gymnasium for our custom MS
would take me one day to replace
word function sus. I'm sure it's a
completely different context
than what I'm doing here.
learn considerably
poly. It depends by what? It depends on
what you mean, Tim. Like, can they scale
with more samples, with more compute,
with different algorithms? What?
Like, no, we're nowhere near capped out,
right? There's a lot more that can be
learned.
What are your recommendations for new
people learning RL? My recommendations
for new people learning RL are
hang on oops
to read the guide that I wrote
specifically for new people learning RL.
There are all of my best suggestions in
one place for you.
If you follow that guide and actually do
what it says then you will learn like
you will know RL and you will be
effective
gymnasium SP3 C3 the slowing down
update steps I was running on some
simulations mat lab
speed uh I was referring to something
completely different Benvant
um that can be an implementation thing
and it can be an M thing.
The command to post this probably
is the correct thing
they say that they decrease N over time.
So they decrease their bootstrap horizon
over time.
I think you have to increase it for
think you increase it
writing custom MS and learning it's
actually really good resource yeah
that's what I try
the memory leak on so Benvan there are
two things if you have an algorithm
that's off Paul and has a replay buffer
then yeah it's going to get slower as
the buffer fills up potentially if it's
not implemented
And two is that if the agent is getting
better, the environments can slow down.
It depends on the task. Typically, you
want to profile stuff. Also, 40k steps
per second anyways. Like, oh, I don't I
guess I don't know the speed you're
training at. Typically, we're doing our
experiments at hundreds of thousands to
millions of steps per second.
just in super simple repeated games with
like matrix payoff multiple agents point
using puffer or other better than gem.
Uh you may as well just go ahead and
implement the environment in Python is a
super quick thing if you want but puffer
is still good because like we have a
fast stable uh implementation with some
substantial advancements that make it
more stable and perform better. Like
there's just a lot of good stuff in
Puffer because you're not going to be
able to use gymnasium to train anyways,
right? You realize this like gymnasium
is not a training library. You still
need to go get a training library and
ours is the best.
If you don't want to use Puffer, the
next best thing would be to use Clean RL
cuz it's very, very simple, even simpler
than Puffer, but it's not going to be
able to get the speeds uh that you get
out of Puffer LIIB. And because it's
slower, like the default settings are
not going to be able to get the
stability that you get out of puffer
either.
Definitely don't go for SP3 though or
something like that or torch or any of
I'm currently coding all my algorithms
by hand. Yeah, that's not going to work
at all. I can guarantee you that's not
going to work at all.
RL is not a field where you just roll
your own stuff when you're new or even
when you're substantially experienced.
These things are incredibly incredibly
brittle and especially if you're just
rolling your own thing and just like
testing it on your environment, nothing
is going to work. Our implementations
are tested across literally dozens of
different environments and used by
hundreds of people.
I know that's not a fun answer because I
also like to do a lot of stuff myself.
This is not a area where you do that.
m and numpy. Yeah, we do our m and c
then like everything is really really
fast.
If you have to do a vectorzed thing,
numpy is fine. But generally, it's as
the end gets more complicated, it's
easier to just write your code. Like you
just get to write arbitrary logic and
loops and stuff and not have to
vectorize or anything. And it's just C,
so it's fast.
Like even if you're used to high level
programming, it's definitely worth
picking up. It's just so much easier.
I'm doing like Q-learning. Do you think
it's a problem? Yeah, because if you're
doing Q-learning, then it's just not
going to work. Like if you're like basic
Q-learning, basic Q-learning is just a
terrible algorithm,
assuming you're doing deep Q-learning at
the very least.
If you're literally doing tabular RL,
then yeah, like but you're not like
you're really not going to solve
anything at that point.
I mean, you're literally going to have a
factor of a million difference uh in
speed if you're just doing like basic
naive algorithm implementations from uh
from scratch versus using something that
is well optimized.
We can train networks from scratch on a
variety of different tasks on one
machine in seconds.
At the very least, I would definitely
take a look at it because it'll broaden
your horizons quite a bit. Um,
like you're not like you're actually not
even going to learn very much about RL
just by trying to implement your own
Q-learning based stuff. Like you're
basically just going to get really
frustrated that nothing works and then
stop doing it.
recommend
it in C. I'm using SP3 implementations
deeplated
for numpy. Yeah. So, I would just do I'd
first I just take your N uh write a
super quick binding to Puffer even in
Python. Try that out and then if you
want to make the end really fast if the
N is a bottleneck, port that to C and
follow our guides on how to do that. For
most things, you're going to be training
millions of steps per second and stuff
will just work instantly.
Massive difference.
What projects would you suggest for
somebody trying to get into RL? Um, the
stuff that's in my guide on X
like I basically take people through
doing a series of like simple to more
complex ends is the idea.
What paper you reading? This is bigger,
better, faster.
Um, I'm not necessarily trying to
replicate this or anything. I'm just
looking for like what techniques help
them scale a little bit.
I'm trying to figure out how this
receding update horizon maps to
on Paul.
I think the equivalent of this is
actually going to be
isn't it to increase the horizon in on
Paul
because you get a biased estimate in off
Paul when you make the horizon longer
don't you
but then you get a a less biased
estimate with onpaul
developing my final project in
university. Wanted to know if you have
some favorite papers related to animal
cognition that has practical examples.
Uh I do not know any papers related to
animal cognition and I certainly don't
know any that have practical examples.
you know, a bunch of like sort of um
like predator prey style motivated RL
stuff, but the animal cognition is like
at best very very distant
paper authors.
Sometimes they are. Honestly, some of
the contributors in here have gotten to
be very good.
Huh?
They use a crap ton of weight decay.
Wait, this is weird though. This is like
This is not a normal value. Did they
just go take this from
They actually got a meta reviewer who's
not a dick. Whoever this guy is, good
job.
Okay. So, this is a different form of
weight decay.
it's like a generalization bias. It's
not relevant in what we normally do, but
it is relevant in um or it's possibly
relevant in the lower data regime.
Implement some new systems with puff.
We're looking at electrical control
system.
Is there a way when I finish to send it
through so others have access? Yes,
absolutely. If you implement an
environment and like working RL around
puffer, you just contribute as an
environment to ocean. This is the
standard way that we run the whole
project.
What the heck? Oh, this is 8 years.
Okay, this is like actual torch. Like
lua torch.
Okay.
So we'll try this for Muan I suppose cuz
presumably this is not implemented
You do not know the horrors this field
used to go through. All right.
The used to actually be a step up from
what we used to have to deal with.
original torch was not pietorch. It was
just torch and it was written in Lua.
You had to do all your damn RL in Lua,
which to be fair, it's not terrible, but
like
Go ask Gro again.
I actually don't know.
Okay, actually we can do this. This be
faster.
Google it
I'm not a roboticist, man.
First dynamics for question. I like I'm
not a roboticist. All I know is you need
to keep the simulator fast
and not try to like make it high
fidelity before you know that that
fidelity is actually needed.
I see this is actually AdamW.
So then do we think it's implemented
correctly in Muan
already?
probably
given that it's the shared with Adam W.
See what we have on our experiment so
far.
Well, you think my Q-learning would be
problematic if I don't use a training
library? Is it pretty common to make all
the code for it? Especially considering
it's a are are you doing tabular
learning or deep Q learning
like basically anything more complicated
than cartpole? Yeah. Then anything more
complicated than cartpole you're going
to not have a fun time.
It's not pretty common to make all the
code and actually have it work.
Like you do not know the horrors that
you're about to inflict upon yourself.
You very well should be if you think
that RL is just like one of these things
where oh, you know, I can learn by
implementing stuff from scratch and I'll
get a good feel for how these things
will work. Like that's just simply does
not work in this field because the
algorithms are far too fiddly and
brittle.
Like you really really really want to
start from something that is fast and
stable. And the fastest and most stable
thing now is puffer.
Okay. Okay. So, I mean, we have a lot of
different things in here that
collectively we should be able to get
something out of, right?
And presumably,
is this the one that's screwed?
Oh, no. That's not the one that's
screwed. What's the one that's screwed?
This one
100. No thousand
200.
Same.
Funny. It sounds like you just described
C++ to me, man.
Uh,
worse than C++ is pretty damning.
this beta 2 scale?
Never messed with this.
I mean, this resets thing is pretty
weird, right?
Okay. So, it's uh the discount factor
analing,
the update horizon, uh and larger nets,
possibly the resets.
I'm going to have to think about the uh
the resets cuz like
there's literally not even a way to do
that, is there?
I don't think there even is a way to do
it.
Dreamer and Mr. Q failed.
They're quite bad. Yeah, we're not
porting [ __ ] to Russ. Screw that
language. Um,
yeah. So,
we got a world modeling based thing to
solve Pong
in like a reasonable number of steps as
well. Like a very reasonable number of
steps. And it just wouldn't work on
anything harder. And it's like super
slow and like the scaling trade-off is
just not where it should be. and it's
super complicated and like in the best
case scenario if it were to work
perfectly today it would still be three
months of infra work to try to make it
vaguely efficient. Um
for Mr. Q not quite as bad. It's
I I don't think that these things
actually scale well with data though at
all.
So I'm kind of just trying to see now
this week. I'm sick and tired of these
fancy algorithms and I'm trying to see
just by doing relatively simple things
how much more sample efficiency we can
get out of puffer liib because if I can
make puffer lib like
even if I can make it 10x as sample
efficient as it is now at the price of
like not a crazy amount of compute
then we're already getting to the point
where that's good enough for industry
right like in the vast majority of
situations you have a simulator, you can
spin up more of those simulators.
It's just that they're kind of slow. So
like spending a bajillion GPU hours to
save a few simulator hours is not worth
it either. So like basically if we don't
actually need soda sample efficiency, we
just need a better sample efficiency
compute tradeoff. I can probably do that
without going nuts.
right. Well, we'll try these things
next. Use the restroom real quick and uh
get some coffee as well. We'll go from
there.
Take a second to walk outside a little
as well. My legs are so stiff.
[Music]
Oh
yeah, I've seen that. Weston,
I can't even say. Have I ever done Okay,
I've never done something quite that
stupid, but I've gotten close when I was
new.
Like I've definitely gotten
uncomfortably close to That
These decays are probably actually
useful, right?
The worst thing I've ever done
programming wise was in uh my first
research internship.
I had to write code to process a a word
graph when I didn't know what a graph
was. Meaning I didn't know what like
search algorithms were. I didn't know
what a node was or an edge was or what
to even look up or ask. So I ended up
with like some 14 for loop deep
recursive function from a nightmare. And
uh it did actually somehow work. But
yeah, that should have been like 20
lines of code, not 2,000.
So, not like I was just a natural at all
this crap.
ironically. If anything, I was more of a
natural at writing back when I used to
do that a bunch.
And I strongly suspect that was just
from the ridiculous amount that I used
to read.
And lately, I still do. Just all audio
books that counts.
remember cuz I stopped listening to
books for many months
and it was actually kind of weird. I
would always listen to audiobooks while
I was running
and uh and then when I got pneumonia
like a like for a while after that when
I got out of the hospital I just like
didn't want to listen to anything at all
running. It was kind of weird. I just
wanted silence.
But I'm pretty much back to full health
now. Pretty much.
Got to finish this cut and rebulk and
then I should be good.
A just a uh just audible. Ben, Ben Vand
audible. Mhm.
favorite books.
Um, it's all fantasy and sci-fi.
Honestly, I really don't like I don't
really listen to a bunch of non-fiction.
Uh,
fantasy. I've been listening to The
Furies of Calderon lately. Almost done
with that. Uh, Aragon,
I listened to that when I was way
younger and it holds up very, very well.
I went through the whole Lord of the
Rings series while I was running. That
actually I don't think is I don't think
that actually holds up so well. I I find
the writing quite boring in it.
Red Rising.
What is this?
I actually do need new series
recommendations.
Topian Sci-Fi.
I don't know if I don't know how I like
this Topian Sci-Fi [ __ ] honestly.
It kind of uh I had a funny discussion
with EMTT on on Twitter. Uh
I don't consider the culture to be the
culture series to be dystopian.
Have I listened to Merrtag?
I think I did.
I actually have zero recollection
though.
No, I think I did, but I have zero
recollection of it.
No, wait. I think I do.
Yeah, the Aragon series is amazing. I
really like that.
movie though. I don't watch any of the
movies for these thing. I've never seen
like the Lord of the Rings movies or
anything.
I really don't watch I I actually can't
even remember the last time I watched a
movie. I think it was while I was still
a PhD student. I watched a few good men.
I think that's the last movie I've
watched was like a year plus ago
in LSTMs. What is the intuition behind
this part of the design? Output is
dependent on
hidden plus input and hidden is
extracted from cell gate
and gate is used. Oh man, Kevin, this is
a diagram that everybody studies once
when they're in undergrad or whenever
they're doing their initial uh ML
and then nobody bothers to actually
remember this. And the reason for that
is that it's backed by so many empirical
ablations that like there's really
nothing you can do by like fiddling with
different gate structures that's better
than this.
Let me see.
So, one of these is a forget gate where
it's meant to let you like decide what
information to get rid of. One of these
is an input gate. I think there's like a
cell there like two other ones as well.
But what I would suggest is there's this
like LSTM like Space Odyssey paper or
whatever and they go through all the
different possible architectures and you
can't really do much better.
Didn't I answer this before something?
Did you miss my answer to this? I
thought Hang on.
Was it you that asked this before?
Well, whatever. I'll answer it briefly.
Um, yeah, the the quick answer, you can
go back for my longer one, but yeah, it
is the best place I ever worked. I was
interning there for six months. Um, I
think I pissed off a bunch of Facebook
people because I was going to go intern
for three months. I was took three
months off for my degree and I batched
it with the summer. So, I was going to
spend three months at OpenAI and three
month months at Fair. and I liked Open
AI so much that I just decided to not go
to fair um after I agreed. So yeah, that
probably wasn't great, but it was it was
such a cool place. Was such such a cool
place. Um
okay, then somebody else asked me
like the Dota team there is still the
most inspirational thing I've seen in
research and Alec was there. Alec was
doing awesome stuff. Ilia and Greg are
still two of the people I respect the
most in this field. There were a couple
people I didn't see eye to eye with.
Little bit of internal politicking that
was stupid, but way less than anywhere
else I've ever been.
Was a cool place.
It was funny cuz I thought I was like I
thought I was hot [ __ ] back then. And
I mean, honestly, a lot of the stuff I
said back then wasn't even like totally
off. I'm obviously I'm way better now.
It was a fun time. What do I know about
Deep Mind? I don't know very much about
the internals of Deep Mind. Just what I
can infer from um you know, their
publications,
I don't think that I would do as well at
DeepMind.
the um my style of what I do is matches
a lot better with open AI.
Deep Mind does too much math for the
sake of doing math for my liking.
worked with Amazon. I took one random
internship at Amazon
What do you think about
mini PCs people are promoting for
running local models?
You're going to have to wait a while for
like local models to catch up at a
reasonable price for LLMs. I mean, with
obviously with my work in RL, right, you
can do all this type of research at
home.
All our stuff is super fast. It's going
to take a while for the uh also catch
up. I honestly I doubt people are going
to be buying $20,000 boxes for personal
use.
Um, it's going to be more the case that
like it'll be an enthusiast thing and
then people will run local models when
there are good ones that are just
embedded in applications that they can
just get
and maybe not even then.
Jetson Nano is more for like
on device, right?
You can have a bigger box at home for
this stuff, but I think most likely
people are just going to outsource to
the convenience of cloud with zero
regard whatsoever to privacy like they
always do, unfortunately.
I guess we'll see.
The best case scenario for that type of
stuff is that um somebody gets the
the best case scenario for this is that
of all these stupid AI lobbyists that
are just like trying to lock down the
field, we get one good one who actually
gets like um
like legal privilege applied to
applied to LLM communications.
That would be kind of funny.
I don't know if that'll happen.
How important is
advanced probability lenal deep learning
theory beyond the fundamentals? You'd
have to ask somebody who knows that
stuff. I don't
Uh, it literally knows cosign an alien.
That's funny. Cosign step over. Yep,
this is a correct version.
You are hypothetically offered 100 mil.
Would you join? What's MSL?
pretty much like what I'd have to get
offered is either something that is like
a natural continuation of what I'm doing
now at larger scale that I think will be
a greater benefit to science than what
I'm doing now and at least as good of a
financial benefit to myself or I would
have to basically be offered so much
money that I figure I go do that for you
know no more than like four years and
then I have unlimited capital with which
to just start my own scientific efforts
for the rest of my life.
It'd have to be like one of those two.
Oh, meta super intell. Yeah. Well, I
don't know if he actually has been doing
that or if that's like the rumor.
$100 million signing bonus for I don't
know how long of a contract. If it's uh
if it's a two-year contract then uh with
like good additionals then yeah
Like 100 million is enough to do a lot
of science, but not unlimited science.
I think a billion is enough to do like
unlimited science.
I mean, right, if you're not like a
ludicrously highmaintenance person, at
some point there's like a number above
which you can't possibly spend more on
like personal stuff that to improve your
life in any way, shape, or form.
And then, at least in my mind, the
really big numbers are for doing cool
stuff with unless you're the type of
person to go buy a yacht or something,
in which case, okay.
He is complimentary. I don't know what
he's doing. I just know that when at
least when I
when I was there at Open AI, he was one
of the two people in the field that I
respected the most. That is all I know.
So take that as you
Not having to think is quite boring
actually.
Like honestly, my ideal setting is
pretty much exactly what I'm doing now
with probably a few more days off, but
not as many as I would expect that I
actually like think I want. If that
makes sense.
Why was he overhyping the [ __ ] up?
Because that major breakthrough was made
at Open AI, right?
GPT was open a like GPT2, GPT3 that was
open AI.
He was honestly one of the first ones to
really make the big bet on um on LLM
scaling as much as they would.
I basically told him that when he asked
me like what do I think about
compression as a general form of
learning. I told him like yeah I think
it'll work. I think it'll get really far
but I don't think it's going to solve
everything. I think you need RL for
interactivity.
So far, it seems like
Did they even partner with Microsoft by
GPT3? I thought it was like after,
wasn't it?
I didn't think they'd even done that by
then.
Is this actually consistent or is this
just noise?
Yeah. But when did they actually get
like exclusives? Right.
There was like a I think there were like
different sizes of that. I don't
remember. Matt wasn't there anymore. I
don't have any inside information.
Okay. I think my publication was
originally 2019 from them, but it it was
it had already been there for a while by
then.
I think that the way that we do this,
guys, I think we do.
We do gamma initial
and we do scale.
I honestly think that's more of a human
problem than an algorithm problem.
So one minus the start
divided by scale. Hell.
This is kind of an interesting little
thing that I've done here, right? This
is like a hyperparameter amenable
like a sweepable version of
of cosine decay on this
So the idea here is that instead of
specifying a start and a stop cuz that's
kind of hard to sweep over, right? Cuz
like stop depends on start, you give it
a scale and that is like the reduction
in uh distance to one. So like if you do
uh 0.9 as the start and a scale of 10
then it'll do 1 minus 0.9 is point is
0.1 it'll divide by 10 and then you'll
get like 99 or whatever instead of 0.9.
So you get 10x closer to one.
Why not hard code it? Because if you
hard code it then you can't sweep it.
You want to al like you want to optimize
these things algorithmically obviously
right.
Oh, why do I have this dumb preview live
eating up my Okay,
this
reward based on the current one, right?
How do you handle the algorithm part
We have a CUDA kernel for it.
It's not a long piece of code. It's just
a very crucially important piece of
code.
Thank gosh
wrong with
Okay,
this is now push.
the exact same thing
for all the hypers.
Oh, we have uh we've got protein and
puffer, which is our hyperparameter
algorithm.
Quite good.
Certainly hope it is. I spent long
enough on it.
Okay, so that's one additional piece.
And aside from that, I think we can look
at the architecture scaling for a little
bit, right?
How we doing on experiments
stuff crashing?
No, it's just taking a while.
This is totally broken.
Oh, here it is.
Interesting.
These I mean these are all going to have
to fully finish.
What does protein do?
It optimizes
hyperparameters quite well.
It's available as a standalone single
file as well based on a lot of my own
research.
All right, let me use the restroom real
quick. Take couple minutes and then
we're going to do possibly network
scaling.
Possibly network scaling. We'll have to
see.
You really should be able to do network
scaling, right?
I'll be right back.
No, you don't you don't optimize the
hyperparameters within a single run.
Okay? Like sometimes you specify that
the hyperparameters are like a decaying
value, right? So that they will change
during the course of the run, but you're
just changing like the end points or
whatever at the start of the experiment.
You're not doing like interactive
optimization live. That's almost
completely intractable to do
efficiently.
The thing I'm doing is much more
straightforward and practical. Believe
me,
is like in the sand.
Okay, now
let's go check the impolicy and then
it's so funny to me how this whole paper
gets remembered so much, but like half
of this paper is just like, hey, what
happens if we use a half decent
architecture?
Oh, it's
wait. So this encoder here
it's con and then it's recommen
You can do that, but I don't know what
like what you're trying to accomplish.
You're not going to be able to do that
effectively.
What the heck about the problem that
you're trying to solve specifically
requires that
applying film to my skip connections?
Good job.
Is it normal to be a stuffed chicken
instead of an autoenccoder?
Uh, it's normal to be hungry enough to
eat a stuffed chicken after working on
autoenccoders all day.
You push capitalism to limits. I hardly
see how that how that follows.
Now optimize the hyperparameters not
slowing the algorithm itself
done with slowing
the hell on the agent.
Why can't I send links? Ask YouTube. I
don't have anything custom set.
I would heavily consider you to
re-evaluate your understanding of the
world. That is not how that works
whatsoever. There's plenty of historical
evidence for that as well if you were go
look for it.
Intrinsic interactive RL
Weston
lesson is funny
directive are using error related
potentials for real world human
like why
you're trying to do like this like RLHF
thingy and I don't understand why like
why do you need to do this for your
specific problem
the problem of no the exact opposite
intrinsic. Oh, so you would you can go
look up like the Majoko backflip for
that. I don't know what the paper's
called, but if you look it up, that
should come up. That's not messing with
hyperparameters live, though. That's
something different, man.
That's the reference though if you want
it.
I mean it's going to be you if you're
going to be rude. Like
you basically came into the chat of
somebody who was streaming all like me.
I'm streaming all my research. I've
dedicated the last decade of my life to
en enhancing science. And you come in
here asking me a bunch of [ __ ] about
if I'm causing global poverty with like
absolutely no [ __ ] context for what
I'm doing at all.
Autonomous driving cars training a safer
that is also different. So that is you
have brought up two different things
right. So one is interactive
optimization that's like the Majoko
backflip the other thing is constrained
reinforcement learning which is very
different. You have two very different
things you're mixing there.
You can't let do this. It can't be in
modules. It's not.
Jeez, Jess.
I mean, seriously, like
replacing jobs and optimizing stuff,
that's not remotely exciting to me. It's
like you can actually argue that there
are
like technological progress does require
this to some extent. And often it is a
good thing because it creates other jobs
on top of that. But like besides that,
that's not what I even care about,
right? I care about making some like
real sci-fi tech. You're just not going
to get by any other means. So So
Okay. So, here is
here is our new model. Uh, this thing is
still fast, it turns out.
3.2 mil.
We have
How do you see RL connections to sci-fi
tech? Well, Puffer Lib itself is kind of
sci-fi in a way that we have brand new
programmers making AI for their games
without knowing anything about like game
AI or search or classic methods at all.
just literally by having the thing mash
random buttons until it figures it out.
Um, this has like huge impacts or
everything dependent on simulation in
industry as well as core areas of
scientific research and other fields
that depend on simulation,
right? And if you think of like what if
RL is actually fast and works across the
board, that creates a lot of crazy
stuff. Um, superhuman logistics,
superhuman optimizations in robotics and
control,
uh, accelerated progress in like
materials discovery, drug design, like
lots of areas, urban planning,
elimination of traffic completely.
There's tons of stuff that can be done.
All right, no BDSM in my chat. Thank you
very much.
This is a research dream. Sir, you have
opened the wrong website.
The thing you don't realize, Pepper, is
that as much as I am here entertaining
you on the stream, you are entertaining
me on the stream.
Yeah, man. Definitely get some help if
you're not just trolling.
don't want to do this, right?
I kind of messed it up.
Well,
it'll have to just do both.
Uh, I actually went to Nvidia
last week
and I'm hoping we're going to be able to
do some cool stuff. especially
The thing is something like
there's not a really good way to do that
because
the outcome of hypers being good or not
is dependent on how like what they're
able to learn. So like
in order to do interactive
hyperparameter tuning you need to do
something like populationbased training.
But that algorithm isn't designed for
the setting you're talking about. Like
that algorithm is basically doing what
you're doing, but it's doing it
massively parallel. And it fundamentally
doesn't make sense to do sequentially.
The whole point is that it's parallel.
There's no benefit to doing it
otherwise.
Ah, that's I just I think I did just do
that, right?
I hit the wrong command.
Funny that I remembered.
It can't, right? The whole point of it
is that it's massively parallel.
like interactive hyperparameter tuning
kind of doesn't make a ton of sense.
Like you can partially sort of do a few
things but not like it's not like I see
your problem go oh yeah you have to do
interactive hyperparameter tuning. It's
like I see your problem and think of a
thousand other things on the list first.
Honestly, Weston, that's such a stupidly
easily fixable problem. It's insane to
me that with all the money that these
companies have put in, they haven't
fixed that yet.
I don't know why when I open X it just
default links me to this random account
I looked up to see if it was available.
Cool.
Uh I was I that's the totally the wrong
window, right?
Yeah, but literally all you would do is
you would just make the output text
editable so it could go back and edit
like you give it an editor instead of
just a text And
so we now have six GPUs worth of
experiments running.
It's 3:20.
I have a couple more hours to do stuff.
I'm exhausted.
I want to do a bit more work. I think I
want to do a little bit more work and
end a little bit early. I don't want to
just be done now.
So, let's put this over here. And then
this goes iron.
What do you do after streams?
Um, for the past few weeks, I go either,
well, most days I walk over to dinner.
On Monday, it's clo like the place I go
to is closed, so I order something.
And I usually spend most of my days I
listen to an audio book. I get in the
hot tub for a bit cuz my legs are shot
from running. And I go to bed.
Sometimes I'll play a couple games or
something, but
usually just like listen to my book, get
in the hot tub,
I mean, my first like at least two hours
of every day are spent on hard exercise.
I need a lot of rest.
Uh, I wouldn't get one that would
obviously.
What the hell are they training it on?
Just the current replay buffer.
Oh yeah, they literally are just doing
that. Huh.
So weird.
there's basically like no good way to do
this with online RL, right?
Once you think about building something
to attract viewers,
I mean, the type of viewers I'm
interested in, right, for the most part,
are people who want to actually get
involved with the tech.
Like the goal is not to be like some
random [ __ ] fluencer.
The goal is to actually advance the
science and have everybody who wants to
be involved with that be able to
is it possible to do something like
weight switching to learn separate tasks
or just learn one big kind of
you're better off if I mean what are you
trying to do? Is this for the quadriped?
Like you're probably better off just
having an embedding of the goal. What do
you mean by pseudo? So this is a weird
paper in the sense that they're like
partially resetting the network's
parameters every so often and then they
are uh they're training
like they're doing additional training
for on the new model just using the
uh the existing buffer
the replay buffer.
So this is like kind of specific to
online I mean to offl
because you have this replay buffer.
I mean I do wonder if this is even a
consideration for online RL
because we just we apply so many fewer
updates. This is probably nowhere near
as much of a problem
with Unity.
Yeah, the problem is if you do something
with Unity, it's going to be slow as
hell, right?
I mean, I guess technically there are
things I can do, right? But it's like
it's not going to be something that's as
quick and easy as this. And if I'm doing
stuff with Unity at that, like I may as
well do that for a company
mostly stream the core research
progress.
Something in the future my sort of goal
after I finish this in the robotic arm.
Yeah, you can a lot of the time if you
have the obs and action spaces still
looking the same and you just have
different tasks, you can just give it an
observation of the goal embedding or
like encode it into the reward. I did it
for drones. It's fine. It just works.
I suspect that this is not
remotely as big of a deal.
Because the thing is just the number of
updates applied is way way lower in
onpaul.
Yeah, there is kind of a Unity gymnasium
thing. Slow. I've seen Yeah, I've seen
the AI Warehouse channel. That one's
really cool. Oh, Weston. I forget. Is
that the guy that you know who did uh
Rainbow or is that somebody else?
Human bipedal robot learned to
skateboard.
Yeah, that's a pain. That's going to be
a real pain.
Well,
honestly, humanoids,
are they that difficult? I know humanoid
hands are very difficult.
I actually don't know. I It depends how
many degrees of freedom you have in the
um in the bot or the model.
You can definitely get like a bipeedal
something or other.
They probably have an oblation on this
thing.
Yeah. Okay. AI tango, right?
I actually think of the offpaul stuff I
looked at, that was one of the better
things I saw.
like, you know, I believe that that guy
actually made something work. I'm sure
there's like there's brittleleness.
There's like really a lot of complexity
in the method and such, but it seems a
lot better than a lot of the other stuff
that's out there. I had like a very
balanced approach.
Oh jeez. Why would you ever do this,
man? You have different axes on these.
Okay.
Trying to make Mario Kart physics using
mustaches. Do you see? Yeah.
What happens if you train Majoko for 1
billion steps?
Well, yeah, like stuff will work way
better. It's just that the Majoko M are
slow as hell. You can actually do that
on MJX, though.
But the thing is, you can't do it like
in Puffer like a billion steps. You do
it in under an hour, right?
Like in some of our depending on the end
of like you some of those are in like 10
15 minutes.
Okay. So, you know what? These are just
not particularly good ablations, I
think, is the problem.
Yeah, these are like not particularly
good ablations.
Like they're standard ablations, but I
don't think that they're particularly
informative.
Joke of war. That's a new thing, I
think. Right.
I haven't looked at warp.
I don't do primarily physics, right?
It's general RL.
Yeah. So, this is just straight better
than this.
it perform linearly better the quality
slow down. Uh typically if you have
stuff optimized well then harder smooth
harder M's are log linear
though RL curves can be a little
difficult to predict
like sometimes you get all you get all
sorts of weird shapes depending on like
whether the environment is structured
such that there's just a very hard to
discover trick or if it's like a a
smooth basically like is it the type of
environment where you can smoothly
improve or you improve proven big jumps
by realizing stuff, right? Like if you
think about most games like competitive
games, a lot of competitive games are a
combination of both of those two things,
right?
Okay, so this is just like do a batshit
insane number of gradient steps,
right?
That's what this is.
Uh we have some in it function I haven't
played around with for a long time that
is inherited from clean RL.
I like how it's saying it's it takes
only 10 hours. It takes only 10 hours to
train a 100,000 frames. That is batshit.
I mean, I think that the most amount of
time we're willing to spend on
100,000 frames, like GPU time, is like
minutes, maybe,
Well, in a parallel universe, the CPU
simulating the M runs a million times
faster as well, right?
And then this method is like whatever.
In a parallel universe, people just
write decent code that's actually fast
and then we don't have to worry about
crazy sample efficiency barriers.
It's kind of crazy that you can do this
well just by doing a batshit number of
updates, right?
I researched blasting plas but it's
closed source
a world where people write uh efficient
code. Like the vast majority of
applications today
are like could be a 100x faster.
Vast majority of production code's just
garbage.
Like your applications, your like stupid
chat app should not take 5 seconds to
load. They should load instantly.
Like literally, I've kind of developed
the opinion that if you just give your
devs like really really slow hardware
um for use during development, like it's
not even necessarily going to make the
it any harder for them to do their work.
And then you'll get something that'll
actually work fast on reasonable
hardware.
going to go give uh all the devs like
Pentium processors for running their
mode.
Am I reading this right? that it's
better.
Okay.
So, possibly a self prediction thing.
I should go look at the self-prediction
loss.
What that is?
This crash
might my thing crash
No.
All right. Well, we'll see what this is,
but
decent chunk of stuff.
made a difference in uh Atari, right?
Maybe you do just have to reoptimize the
crap out of everything.
Here's a restroom real quick. I'll be
right back.
I think one I think Neptune's just being
crappy.
Well, we're going to play with a couple
things, I suppose, here just for a
little bit.
Can you
summarize the advances in the algorithm
of the model? Uh the initial screenshot
I posted was literally just the first
sweep that I ran with limited to uh 10
million samples.
So if you just run the hyperparameter
tuner to optimize for something other
than high data regime, you do a fair bit
better. And now we're making additional
changes on top of that.
the other way around. That doesn't make
any bloody sense to me.
Really, this specific learning rate is
so magical.
I wonder if this is related to the uh
gamma being screwy
Auxiliary self-s supervision losses to
work. Uh, not yet. I haven't.
There's evidence for and against those
literally magic learning rate. That's
crazy.
Else we can do for this.
I mean I can mess with some things here,
right?
What happens if I guess hypers?
What happens if I literally just guessed
my hypers? There's
Okay,
we're back up to reasonable PF.
So if I do like
you know
this doesn't instantly solve either
there.
[Music]
100.
Okay. So, something like this could
work.
Interesting.
It's funny that we really haven't seen
much out of model scaling at all yet,
right?
Well, hang on.
If I do like this,
420. Is this
what the heck part of degenerate
search space have I gotten myself into
here?
I haven't done anything that should lead
to degenerate search space, right?
off Paul.
Um,
there's definitely something to sample
reuse,
but all practical forms of incorporating
it have major issues.
So, this is not super sensitive, it
seems.
Man, I shouldn't be messing with these
manually to be fair. I'm just trying to
get a sense of like what I can even Do
Reducing the number of environment
should cause that much of a distinction.
No, wait. We have
that's evaluated over many batches
already, right?
thing I can think of is the batch norm
like not even the batch norm layer the
advantage batch normalization.
But that should not
How the heck is it possible that this
completely
and utterly breaks it?
If this doesn't work, we must just be in
some really unstable regime,
which to be fair, you can actually get
that from sweeps.
Okay. Well, actually the it seems there
are good settings with fewer
environments
if you can go find them.
It just shifts the hypers a bit.
Has not done very much yet.
This is also good. This one here is very
good actually.
Yeah, I like this. Holy.
Yeah, this one's super good.
Okay. So, then there's just the question
of basically putting all these things
together and then whether or not you can
find these in a standalone sweep.
Do you work on this full-time? Yes,
Puffer is technically uh well, not even
technically. I mean, Puffer is a private
lab. It's a company. We have a couple
clients that pay for uh extended work
around our tools.
I've been considering increasing this
for a while now.
Um,
yeah, but for now it's here as is.
Yeah. So, you definitely
This one's definitely good.
What's the time for this one taken? It
was with one. Uh,
yeah, this is literally just 3 minutes.
This is good.
I like this one.
Okay. So, this is just like the way that
they consider frame budgets. They put
the um
they put the number of steps into it.
So, I believe if I just go to 512
one
40 million frames,
this is considered equivalent under
standard definitions.
Any recommendations
for selfplay
like papers or
like what for how to do it?
Look at the Dota paper. Your best
reference
at the moment. Um, yeah, gaming is one
of them, but far from the only one,
right? Low fidelity control,
logistics.
Um, it's random stuff. Even in finance,
we've done animation generation work. We
do stuff with like another
private lab.
Tons of applications.
I mean, honestly,
it's kind of crazy that um
there really are more applications of
this stuff than there are of LLMs if you
really think about it.
It's just that this is uh a lot less
mature
because it hasn't had all the investment
for stability diverges immediately for
simple algorith.
if you fix one of the opponents as
random, does it train? Do that as a
sanity test
and you compete with Gorobi.
No idea who they are. Uh, the idea is
generally that.
But here's the thing, like not
everything is just a mixed integer
problem, right? As soon as real world
problems get messy.
You end up needing to do learning.
And the idea is that RL can handle messy
problems, right?
You don't need to get some clever
mathematical reduction. All you need is
a simulator
and chuck RL at it.
And we've already made RL a heck of a
lot better than it was a year ago.
Massively, massively better.
We can already solve problems now with
just like almost out of the box with
just a little bit of work that would
have taken a team in two years.
Um, and as our all gets better and
better, we will be able to solve more
and more problems using our tech.
Right now I'm working on
I'm working on getting it to be uh to
have a better compute to sample
efficiency tradeoff
What is the core trick that's
um have you done but like have you tried
to train it against a fixed baseline
opponent
honestly longer term I'm way more
interested in like RL applied to
material science and um biology and so
on and so forth.
like the really simulationheavy areas of
science.
That's longer term.
For now, we're going to solve it.
Okay. I mean, this is the regime that
we're interested in though, right? The
regime where like you spend a few
minutes on the problem and instead of
like 30 seconds and you get 10x sample.
Yes. Yes. Fixed random opponent trains
well. Really?
the like most simple and best method for
this is historical selfplay
is in the Dota paper.
Then you're always doing some of your
games against fixed opponents.
Okay. Okay. Well, I mean, this is decent
enough here.
Now, it does occur to me that this is
not exactly the network that I tuned
this for.
I don't have any weird settings. It's
just the defaults
the stream.
forgot this.
That's it.
430.
I think I'm going to reoptimize this
thing for steps.
Just throw everything I've done today at
it.
Okay. Okay. So, it's kind of
coincidental then that it's this wonky
VF clip
still a pretty fast training
over 100k.
I mean to be fair though, right, you can
actually
you can get Atari to be pretty dang
quick
without frame skip.
Let's see if this solves before uh
before 20 mil even.
I mean 40 mil.
It's also possible the update epochs
don't help at all because it's already
maxed.
This is just like
good thing was just trolling me, right?
Okay, having fewer ends
definitely makes there be hyper prams
that are better.
That is definitely the case.
Gamma decay doesn't have enough
experiments to say.
This one doesn't either.
It's nice.
This is nanned out.
Not good.
Maybe four is too much.
When is RL a bad idea? when your problem
doesn't fundamentally require
interactivity
or when you have like unlimited expert
data
or when you want to not be driven crazy
by insane research.
I wouldn't be surprised if you can
actually solve this thing in like 5 mill
steps or whatever.
Yeah, cuz this is pretty much solved
here, right?
Yeah. So this is
this is solid. 2 minutes
10 mil samples.
Okay. Well, I think it makes sense now
for me to just set up set up a sweep
that incorporates everything I've come
up with so far, right? Um,
I guess what we'll do,
we'll cut it down to like 20 mil.
Can I do blocks in um
well, let's not do
not do crazy blocks yet, right?
You like Atari 100k
that meaningful
I could actually do a really big sweep
of that
They just did direct joint and tro
direct
joint and torque.
Oh yeah.
Why don't you Can you just do that and
have it work?
Can you just do that and have it work?
That'd be good.
Did I ever tell you to do IK? I thought
I told you to do FK, not IK.
Okay. So, there you go.
This will sweep.
And then I think what I'm going to do is
I'm going to call it a bit early today.
And I'm just going to kind of monitor
that monitor this and keep doing some
experiments at relatively small scale,
but not so small as to be just totally
stupid. And then we'll just start
pushing this slowly into sample f
regime. And then what we'll do is we'll
take 3 0 which we know what the data
efficient regime is. We'll take the
sample efficient regime and then we'll
figure a way to cover them both in 40 as
well as integrate a few other things and
updating my output layer.
Weston, this is a lesson in keeping your
damn code clean.
Like that's how you not waste time on
this stuff.
Fun fact, by the way, so film was film
was the reason that my uh first vision
paper didn't get accepted cuz it like it
was published they got it out like right
before I could publish mine and uh
it was on the same benchmark with like
basically the same performance.
This was my my original vision paper.
This was like this crazy architecture
where you assemble
like this forking like dynamic neural
net for every single question you want
to answer.
And then it was like semi-ifferiable
which was cool.
Yeah. So, I think what is it? We beat
them on this is actually film here
and I had a much smaller network
and I beat them I think on like this
category and then on the overall
with like a tiny little neural net which
was cool.
Theirs was like more scalable and didn't
use all these annotations and yada yada
yada but like I had this tiny little
neural net and it actually did pretty
well.
I don't know. I was probably like 20
when I did this.
Okay.
Well, it's about five. Um,
I think I'm just going to call it
slightly
early today.
I'm going to go get myself dinner
and uh I'm going to take it a little
easy today and then tomorrow.
So, tomorrow I have a super like
obnoxiously early, very long meeting.
Um, which is going to delay me.
And then if as long as it's not 90°, I
got to go run in the moderate heat and
then I should be here for a few hours in
the afternoon to work on this stuff.
So, for the folks who have been watching
all day, thank you for stopping by.
This is a nice bit of progress on the
initial sample F research.
I think
my best guess is we're going to be able
to do like 20x sample efficiency
um with like 10x compute. 10 to 20x
compute. That's my best guess.
I think we're going to get like a pretty
clean tradeoff
up to a point.
I don't know whether the results are
going to be as stable across everything.
That is the concern.
So, we will see about that.
But yeah, this is all open source work.
Checkpuffer.ai AI for details. Go to the
repo. It's free. Helps me out a lot. If
you want to get involved with the
project, join Discord. It's a lot more
accessible than you might think. If
you're trying to get into RL, you can
follow me on X for more content,
including all of my guides. Thank you,
and I will be back tomorrow. Bye.